ich grüße sie erstmal großen respekt
dass wir diese weise durchgesetzt haben
und auch angetreten haben wir wollen
über drei punkte jetzt reden ich hoffe
wir schaffen also in unserer zeit wir
fangen mal an mit dem was sie erlebt
haben dort was sie vom krieg mitbekommen
was sie uns berichten kann
erst mal waren wir ja in
anführungsstrichen nur in der west
ukraine da ist es relativ friedlich
selbstverständlich sieht man viele
panzersperren viele sandsack barrieren
viele bewaffnete wir haben gesprochen
intensiv mit abgeordneten vom
ukrainischen parlament wo die
forderungen klar waren mehr waffen
energie im balco mehr unterstützung wir
haben ein krankenhaus besucht und haben
damit ukrainischen soldaten gesprochen
die zum teil schwerst zuletzt waren die
sehr sich gewünscht haben mit uns zu
sprechen um uns ihre botschaften zu
überbringen dass sie einfach auf
deutlich mehr unterstützung
das ist dann schon heftig was man erlebt
hat und dann waren wir noch bei dem
lager des bombardiert worden ist von der
russischen armee waren sie
wahrscheinlich eine sehnsucht nach
frieden gespürt aber auch einen großen
großen wunsch für hilfe also wir nennen
mal die dinge die von ihnen drei
nachgekommen sind schon kohle öl embargo
und schwere waffen wie schaut es damit
aus
wir sind der meinung das ist dringend
notwendig ist die ukraine stärker zu
unterstützen
die wehrt sich verzweifelt gegen einen
vernichtungskrieg es wert sich eine
demokratie gegen eine verbrecherische
agierende diktatur es werden jeden tag
schwere kriegsverbrechen begangen von
den russischen invasoren in der ukraine
und da ist es unsere pflicht sie zu
unterstützen und das gleiche haben wir
erlebt wir sind wahnsinnig warmherzig
empfangen worden man hat uns sogar
gesagt dass ein verständnis dafür gibt
dass deutschland schwierigkeiten hatten
gas embargo zu machen aber dann erwarten
sie wenigstens ein erdöl- und ein kohle
embargo obwohl ich mir mit ihnen einig
dass eigentlich sogar ein glas in
barking aber wenigstens sollten wir
schnellen erden gas-embargo durchsetzen
und sie haben im grunde große hoffnungen
auf deutschland und würden sich wünschen
dass unser kanzler endlich die
verantwortung übernimmt den kanzler
eines so großen und wichtigen landes in
europa hat ja da gibt es eine diskrepanz
der gefüllt und auch wahrscheinlich eine
reale auch was die waffenlieferungen
betrifft was braucht die ukraine was hat
man ihnen gesagt
sie brauchen im kern alles von munition
über leichte waffen bis zu schwere
waffen aber sie brauchen insbesondere
auch schwere waffen und sie brauchen
insbesondere auch waffen westlichen typs
einig es wird inzwischen verzweifelt
versucht in der ganzen welt altes
russisches und sowjetisches material
zusammen zu suchen auch da sollten wir
helfen aber dieses material ist nach und
nach zerstört
und dann brauchen sie russland große
vorräte hat der russische präsident
diesen krieg unbedingt auf biegen und
brechen fortsetzen will und dann
brauchen sie jetzt bereits westliches
material damit sie in den nächsten
wochen ihre soldaten darauf trainieren
kann wenn das alte russische
theoretische material alles zerstört ist
so eine reise hat ja quasi zwei teile
also die eigentliche reise und haben die
rückkehr und das was sie dann hier
erreichen wollen was glauben sie erstens
wo hängt hier bei uns dass uns so häufig
vorgeworfen wird wir zögern und zaudern
zu viel und wo sind die die
lösungsmöglichkeiten wo sind die hebel
die gelegt werden müssen
es muss die verständigung im kabinett
dass wir keine schweren waffen liefern
muss verändert werden es muss ganz klar
aus dem kanzleramt gesagt werden ich
erwarte von allen zuständigen
ministerien und annalena baerbock und
robert habeck fordern ist ja selbst dass
jetzt alles getan wird um die ukraine
auch mit waffen zu unterstützen
das ist die verantwortung des kanzleramt
und dann müssen wir auf europäischer
ebene im minimum dafür arbeiten dass es
ein energie embargo im minimum öl und
kohle gibt und wenn deutschland seine
meinung ändert daran bin ich fest davon
überzeugt was ich aus nahezu allen
anderen europäischen ländern gehört
haben nahezu alle anderen europäischen
länder ihre meinung wir haben ja de
facto fast nur noch ungarns orban als
verbündeten was das erdöl und kohle
embargo man geht und das kann einfach
nicht sein ich würde mal ganz kurz rein
pixeln an die koalition hängt zwar bei
der spd fallen
ich würde sagen es hängt vor allem im
kanzleramt der kanzler muster
führungsstärke zeigen und muss sagen wir
beenden unsere alleingänge und wir
sorgen jetzt dafür das ist zu einem
gemeinsamen kohle und öl embargo kommt
in meinen augen wäre sogar ein energie
im wago notwendig und dass wir deutlich
mehr liefern und dass wir die ukraine
eine beitrittsperspektive anbieten er
braucht eigentlich die bundesregierung
braucht das kanzleramt einen weckruf
wäre dann beispiel zu also die ausladung
des bundespräsidenten steinmeier ein
solcher weckruf schnell und mehr für die
ukraine zu tun oder ist es ein
strategischer fehler von seiten der
ukraine gewesen auszuladen ich glaube es
war ein strategischer fehler von seiten
der ukraine aber ich glaube sogar
eigentlich zu kleiner strategischer
fehler aber man hat der einzelnen
vergessen die ukraine wehrt sich gerade
verzweifelt seit wochen gegen einen
vernichtungskrieg und deshalb sollte man
auch großzügiger sein und die dinge tun
den man augen jetzt notwendig ist das
ist nicht nur notwendig für die menschen
in der ukraine für die verteidigung von
freiheit und demokratie es auch
notwendig für uns wir verlieren gerade
in ganz europa natürlich noch mal
besonders in ost und mitteleuropa aber
in ganz europa ansehen wir verlieren
geostrategischen einfluss wir verlieren
damit am ende auch ökonomische
möglichkeiten deshalb ist in unserem
eigenen interesse dass deutschland da
endlich mehr führungsverantwortung
übernimmt überall hört man wir warten
auf deutschland wir freuen uns sehr über
ihre sehr deutlichen worte und appelle
dankeschön anton hofreiter
ich danke ihnen